[音楽]
偶然球技大会バスケットボールの部2年連続優勝
肇社長ですバスケットゴールやってる人いると思うんですけども
ゴールにボールのシューズは非常に難しい
非常に難しいのでやっぱの僕もはラケットの経験者の都市でもやっぱりねすげー
完璧にシュートが入ることで中ではないんですよ別が私を覚えていてしまいますが私を
持っていてしまいました皆さんズシャッうっていうご存じですね磁石そうですじゃあ
ごっちゃんです弱で s 極と n 極があるんですよ
結局定食だと反発やって塩極と n 極だと反発しちゃう
は s 極と n 極だとくっつき合うんであのめちゃくちゃ強い磁石れるんです
ちょっと買ってきたんですけど
ああ
ネオジム磁石でこの超強力なチェックをあのだいたい約2分ほど買いましたでこの磁石
を使って例えばバスケットボールを全部 f 曲
バスケットゴールの中ディングの周りとか防曇同2円な曲をつけると
だから多少な適当なない方しても絶対に集とか入るバスケットゴールができるんじゃ
ないかと思いまして挑戦者でも絶
ブーバー一粒だしていきましょうつできたらコレ
を超えます
俺は指とか挟んだらでだいたいじゃあ
コナへ
ん
えっポスト無傷に反応してますね
で乳首みたいいただけていきましょう
第一台一台
[音楽]
はい類がネオジムじゃ結構出ましたも多分100個以上はあるいますねこれで1角で着
ですからねぇ
あっへっもうこれだけでねこれほどない彼だっ
と思います頑張れば取れるぐらいですね最適で次の過程に入れましょう
次はまずバスケットボールに磁石をすべきます全ての近くには s 極があり n 極
があるそれが磁石ですこの大手目に発展します多分この作業が一番大変な気がすんだよ
これ宝庫間違えたらマジで一生ボールに入らないバスケットボールができるかもしれ
ないんできょうつけ貼っていきましょう
を
大丈夫これバスケットボールの演習ぐらいのが無蛍光準備しこれが大手になるように
貼ってよいいんでしょたぶん
[音楽]
ん
tan
あった
[音楽]
ん
んだ
持ってってやばい爪が取れちゃう
魅力的には問題ないですただこれやばいん
すぐくっつくよねじゃあバーン
がっしり者
rar
アッシュとドリブルできるか不安でねー
あ全然できるできるなんとかできますね
入ったけどバスケットゴールにつけていきましょう向きはマジでミスっちゃダメなんで
こんなまっくっついてくれたら一番
あっ早いなんかそのまま
neko くっついてくれるんでこのままつけていきましょう
[音楽]
はいはいはいおっけーすこれでリング周りは完成しましたあなたが愛でる固定してい
ます
どうでしょうで続いてはここを受けたボードですねボールが当たるとリングに入るって
言われてるんでここにも尽きていこうと思います
よし完成しましたこれが我々の
すべている1
やった急いで作った最強のバスケットゴールできたぞ
これが n 極バスケットゴールです
バッハ
あっはぁ2位に完成てしまった
キャッツで俺が中3の時伊藤ある高校のバスケ部から水深が来るほどのまあまああそ
こそバスケットができた男がついに
米州をせずにポイって投げるだけで防具が居るに入ってしまうそんな素晴らしい研究を
思いついてしまった
こんなボールズ香炉すればどんな習得も必ず入るはず
複数実に
ファイル素敵なシュートを見せてやると思いますエグゼ
しまーす
4日
んだった
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
ああああああ
ん
スレ ana
これ関係ではなかった授業は関係ありますした夜中パパ